there there was a video that
popped up on saturday that seemed to
breathe
life into this idea that drew brees who
has
still not announced his retirement even
though it was expected weeks ago by the
saints
maybe he won't be retiring a trainer
posted this video
to social media late last week take a
look
have a listen and ask yourself does drew
brees look like somebody who's just
trying to get a little exercise in or is
he preparing for something more
significant than just staying in shape
i don't know where he's going let's go
time is on go where we going maui
come on tim to the black and back
through to the black
the black drew true to the black
drew what is he doing
what is he doing he said to the street
drew
what are you doing okay he's never
done that
hurry up don't know what he's doing
tv come on what oh my god
i'm not sure what he's doing never quite
been done before
he needed a challenge i said black and
black
that's a new record because it's never
been done before
i i did you notice that something must
be brewing
yes that was placed over the video and i
can't figure out quite what it is that's
never been done before i've seen guys
push sleds before for more than 50
seconds so
it all felt a little too hokey from the
guy who was providing the narration
but still drew brees not looking like a
guy who
is fading quietly into the night chris
no definitely
well and definitely not um i think what
he's talking about if that's even him
i think that's him the hair for some
reason looked a little different to me
but but we have to be sure that was him
but but we're 99.9 percent confident
that it is you're on fire today huh i
mean what what what did you eat this
morning okay
but nothing but either way him well i
think what first off when he's talking
about he's never done that before he was
supposed to stop where
like it the the the hill starts to go
down and then turn around and come back
so
he went above and beyond but of course
yes
they obviously made the video and all
the
you know graphics after the video
so there was some intent there
something i don't know but that those
exercises
i mean they don't get any harder than
that drew brees phenomenal athlete all
that
i don't think you're doing that type of
exercise just to look good at the beach
you know in california later that day
just so you look good in your bathing
suit or anything like that
that's a that's a drill you do that
you're
going i need to be explosive i need to
still be fast and twitchy and strong and
have good endurance
which is all football-based stuff so i
mean i hear you mike i'm with you that
that to me sounds like a guy and looks
like a guy that thinks he's
still gonna play football next year and
that's what's weird about it because
i didn't expect him to be trying to play
football and i don't think the saints
did either
is it possible that this entire
narrative that drew brees is done
after 2020 was hatched by the saints
in an effort to kind of speak it into
existence and that brees never really
intended
and still doesn't intend to walk away
and if anything the fact that he feels
like he's
being nudged is making him more
determined to come back
is that possible i i 100 percent think
that's the reason
i really do a man like drew brees
everything we know about him
to this point i think he's going like
screw you
you know sean payton anybody else mickey
loomis whatever
i'm gonna go out on my own terms i i
mean i i do think he's probably
you know was a little offended by maybe
some of the cryptic
language sean payton used before the
season started last year
and then you know of course when sean
payton was on the show with us
saying all of those type of things so
that's where it's going to get dicey
here
and they've already put themselves out
the limb already was with mickey
loomis's comment
to say if drew wants to come out come
back
you know he's coming back so now they're
kind of boxed into a corner and that's
where
i think it's going to get interesting
and i don't know where this exactly goes
four weeks ago wednesday payton told us
that they expect an announcement within
a week to a week and a half
from brees and it was after their
playoff
ending loss to the buccaneers that
peyton was asked about drew brees
retiring and he said that's a topic for
another press conference which told us
everything we needed no in that same day
jay glazer
reported on fox that breeze is done
when the season's over so again how much
of this is saints driven
how much of it is breeze driven how much
of it is
breeze was intending to retire chris but
then he saw what
older man tom brady did at 43
beating the saints in the playoffs after
the saints swept the buccaneers in the
regular season
winning the super bowl the team that the
saints beat 38-3
won the super bowl how do you not
if your drew brees convince yourself
that i have to try it again i will
regret it the rest of my life
if i don't try it again because i will
always think
in 2021 we could have gotten back to the
top of the mountain well i know that's
how i would feel i know
well the problem is is he gonna he's
gonna feel like that after 2022 and then
he's going to feel like that after 2023
and you know first off we don't know
where did the jay glazier report come
from we don't know where he got it from
if he didn't
you know well if he didn't get it from
drew brees then drew brees is going to
be pissed off about that too
to add to the list of the other things
we've already mentioned i think
also you know the tom brady point you
make
i i think probably puts a little fuel
into that fire i i don't think there's
any doubt about that i mean as a
ex-competitor and i'm not trying to
compare myself to brady or breeze or
anything like that but
i can certainly you know put myself
in their shoes as far as that standpoint
and a guy that he's kind of competed
against his
whole career college nfl and he sees him
doing these type of things
but but there's a big big
butt there is a much difference
big difference in tom brady
at this point of his career compared to
drew brees yes drew
you know tom brady at the end in new
england you know
we still saw talent we just went
he can't carry the team anymore it's not
that anymore
but as we saw if you put talon around
him
he and you get him in the right
circumstance he
can really be awesome still that's
i'm sorry i i but i don't think that's
the case with drew brees
i don't you know there is issues in his
game
there's major flaws and it
shows on their team and especially
in big games and the playoffs against
better defenses and things like that
all let alone let's not forget they
don't struggle when he's not there
all they do is win football games when
he's not there
and we know again like we talked about a
little last week
yes his arm's never been one of the
great arms ever
but his arm was always good enough to
where he could scare you with the deep
ball in certain throws
there's too many games now where it's
forget the deep throws it's can he
can he consistently make 20-yard throws
and scare defenses that way
and you know drive a ball into tight
coverage man-to-man coverage and do that
oh here's a window
can he drive the ball into that window
you know yeah okay
maybe he can get away with it with the
the weak
the less than in the nfl as far as those
defenses are concerned
but when it comes to the upper echelons
of teams in football aka the playoffs
and those playoff defenses
we've seen those flaws kind of
rise to the top and uh that's where it's
a whole different story to me
at least in my opinion compared to tom
brady at his
at their points of their careers yeah
look i uh i don't know where this goes
mike this
i don't know i mean just my heart of
hearts says
the saints like you said were thinking
about
life after drew and let's move on and
let's do those things
and now and i it seems like they fully
expect it i don't think mickey loomis
makes that comment
unless he expects drew brees to retire i
really don't
i think he said that to be gracious to
the fans and be like hey
we're not pushing him out the door you
know
you're right it's when you have it's
when you have relatives visiting and you
tell them stay as long as you like yeah
exactly until they get the hell out yes
stay oh we love you and you're here all
week we love it and you're really you
know going to your wife going
i mean wasn't three nights enough i mean
how many [ __ ]
um boy you sound like somebody who's
been there i have
so uh but i'm tempted to push it even
farther but i won't because that's a
door that swings both ways
all right um here here we go
here we go yeah uh the one
thing that continues to make me think
he's done
is the idea that he dropped his salary
from 25 million down to the minimum of
1.075 million with nothing else to make
that money back up
which to me was the the final nail
that's it he's done he's giving
nine two up million dollars period it's
gone
but now i'm starting to think this is uh
when he says i'm well i'm ready to come
back and i'm only making 1.075 million
and look at how low my cap charge is
this year
it really makes me wonder is there some
sort of
broader back and forth here where
he he wants them to tell him to go away
that that and whether he intends to play
or not and maybe he genuinely wants to
play but
there's a another category here of
for whatever reason he wants them
to tell him to go away he doesn't want
to be the one
to go which makes no sense no because
he's 41
there's no shame in retiring it's not
like he's quitting on new orleans
everyone's expecting it so i i disregard
that
i think if this thing goes against what
we thought
and it already is it already is against
what we thought or at least what sean
payton thought we're almost four weeks
removed from payton telling us they're a
week or a week and a half away from an
announcement
the only logical conclusion becomes he's
seriously considering
coming back that's the only logical
conclusion
i don't he does he's never seemed like a
guy who needs the attention
right is he getting any enjoyment out of
the fact that
we've spent the first 15 minutes of
today's show
talking about whether or not drew brees
is actually retired i with all he's
accomplished in his life and all the
things he will accomplish going forward
he doesn't strike me as the kind of guy
who would be that vain
that he would want us to be speculating
on whether or not he's going to keep
playing i don't believe that
so all i can believe is he's seriously
thinking about playing i
i i i hear you i think i i think he's
seriously thinking about playing two and
i think there's another aspect that you
you know you kind of
hit on or at least that jumps out to me
at least
you know stars can lose reality
i i i stars can lose track of reality
they really can you know again he is a
guy
that has overcome tremendous obstacles
his whole life and he's been a star and
he's the man
i mean he's the man he really does i
mean
you know i don't know we might be
working with him next year i hope he
doesn't beat me up when he gets here
okay but either way
you know he yeah he you're like he might
uh but
but he might and i'll stand and watch
i'll have the popcorn
yeah i don't have your back quarterback
versus quarterback i'm getting the hell
out of the way i saw what he did to that
sled yeah
sorry i'm gone yep yep yep yeah i know
so don't get involved that's quarterback
stuff but
i do think stars can lose
sight of reality and where they are as
far as
the player and where they are at this
aspect of this career
listen i can go back to kobe bryant
r.i.p kobe bryant one of the greatest
basketball players i've ever seen
i can remember at the end of his career
he's he's on the practice
or the espn ranked him as the 37th best
basketball player in the nba
and he kind of scoffed at it like it was
ridiculous and it
and you know i'm you know me i'm an nba
watcher i was like they were kind of
being kind by putting you at 37. i
thought i mean
but he didn't think that he still
thought like that's crazy i'm you know
he was i'm top
20 i'm top 25. and i don't like saying
that about kobe bryant or anything like
that but
i just use that as a reference point to
show
that you know that these guys they are
who they are because they're so
stubborn in their brain and they do
believe in their ability to perform and
be great and do those things
and within that you can lose sight of
reality
of where you actually are uh as a player
and i think maybe the saints might have
to have that conversation with drew
brees at some point i i do i think we're
getting to that point where they might
have to
at least from my standpoint keep it real
last thing i'll say here
or no that's it for now i'm picturing
you know what though i
i'm picturing sean payton with you know
his big monitor up and the clicker and
just showing him
20 different plays and and comparing
five years ago to now same play drew
look at how you threw it in 2015.
look at how you threw it last year here
look at the next one look at how you
threw it then look at how you throw it
now
right drew i'm just telling you it ain't
gonna get any better
if you if you come back in 2021
you got to ask yourself is this what you
want to do is this how you want to go
out is this how you want to be
remembered i mean that's a tough
conversation it's tough
for for bro for brees and peyton to have
but
don't i is it going to come to that it
may have to come to that well and into
what you just said right there like look
at this play compared to that play four
years ago
he'll be able to go look i haven't been
able to call this play
in four years i can't call this play
that we called four years ago
because i i don't think it's capable of
you know
being executed at this point of your
career other thing here too
and again it's drew brees legend
i mean first ballot hall of famer i
understand that i never feel proud
saying these type of things
because you know i i i just i've been
around quarterbacks my whole life
but we saw them win
games this year with taysom hill they
lost what one one game with him they're
just the
was it yes right last year they went 5-0
with teddy bridgewater
teddy bridgewater is being back
relegated to career backup and he
they're done with him in carolina
he's he's not a like a special starter
or anything
and he was able to go 5-0 against some
pretty damn good teams
that year too it wasn't like he beat
like a bunch of cupcakes they went up to
the seattle and beat the seahawks in
seattle
you know they beat the bucks they beat a
few other teams so uh
you know there's something to be said
there too
just as far as where drew is at so i
don't know but uh i i think the saints
in them
are drew sean payton and company are
going to have to have a pretty
heart-to-heart conversation here keep it
real and get things figured out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports